وكانها سكنه ومسرح مداهمات لا مدينه اعتاد
فيها اكراد ايران على التجوال في مهاباد
تسن قوات الامن الايرانيه حمله اعتقالات
وقمع ضد المحتجين الذين بداوا برفع سقف
المطالب والطموح معها من التحقيق
بالاعتقالات التعسفيه الى الحريه واسقاط
النظام المدينه تشهد حركه عسكره كبيره
وافادت منظمه حقوقيه بان السلطه او فدت
قوات مسلحه الى مهابات من اورميا في
محافظه اذربيجان الغربيه وسط معلومات عن
اطلاق نار
رافقتها فيديوهات متداوله تظهر اقحام
الامن الايراني بالطائرات المسيره
لاستهداف ورصد المحتاجين ووفق مواقع
للمعارضه فالسلطات الايرانيه لم تكتفي
بالاعتقالات والقمر
وماذا تتفق تقارير للمعارضه الى هدم منازل
مواطنين في مهبات بتهم استهداف قوات الامن
بدوره اشار موقع ايران انترناشونال الى ان
القوات المسلحه تتجول بالسيارات في مهابات
بدون توقف في وقت يصف مواطنون اكراد اجواء
المدينه بانها تشبه اجواء الاحكام العرفيه
وتشكل مدينه وهباد ذات الثقه للكردي نقطه
احتجاج جديده تسع السلطات الايرانيه على
مدى الاشهر الثلاثه التي ثلاث مقتل مهسا
اميني الى اخمادها لكن بدون نجاح يذكر
اقله حتى الساعه